hop hop hop hop ya trop de zoom là
comment ça va comment vous allez
aujourd'hui j'espère vous allez bien ici
c'est plutôt la pêche alors aujourd'hui
on va parler de quoi on a parlé de sang
a donné un petit peu un retour complet
sur le chien au 1012 promise avec moi
depuis quelques temps ces pannes amusé
avec nous et parler de chiens 2012 ya
pas longtemps je sais pas si vous l'avez
vu je vous invite à venir voir la vidéo
de test du chiot midouze prowler on s'en
doutera qui dit modèles professionnels
dic ont fait plus de choses dit qu'on
aura plus de performances des qui se
passera plus de trucs ok alors j'attends
un chiot 1012 ultra j'espère qu'il va
arriver j'ai posé la question à chez au
mime on ne peut pas te répondre jamais
de réponse mais en tout cas ce chien au
1012 pro est cool il ya des choses qui
vont bien il ya des choses qui vont un
peu moins bien et ce qui est surtout
intéressant si vous voulez je ne sais
pas si vous le savez je pas si vous êtes
coutumier de ce sommet mais chut hormis
les smartphones très haut de gamme c'est
pas la wiimote à de plus gros volumes de
vendeurs sa règle générale assez connu
c'est tous les vendeurs de smartphones
là où les choses se font le plus haut il
ya plus de vent que c'est dans le milieu
de gamme néanmoins ici c'est vachement
intéressant parce que depuis deux ans
schumi tarridec des smartphones haut de
gamme très haut de gamme les tarifs on
monte on est gamin plus de 1000 euros le
smartphone autant vous dire à vous pour
y aller et le client initiale de chez
home il n'avait jamais prévu m 1000
euros sera smartphone de chez un ami
pour autant est-ce que les smartphones
de shiomi aujourd'hui peuvent se mettre
face à des samsung façade et apple et
surtout est-ce que ce smartphone là peut
convaincre est ce qu'il est intéressant
qu'est ce qu'il raconte qu'est-ce qu'on
va regarder aujourd'hui ben oui
[Musique]
le premier ticket connaître ce
smartphone dans la famille des usages je
demande le multimédia je demande la
qualité d'écran je demande la qualité
des haut parleurs je demande le
visionnage de films de séries ça c'est
ce qu'on fait c'est un des usages
primordial est plus important
aujourd'hui au niveau des smartphones et
c'est justement ce qu'on peut venir
retrouver ici en fait ce qu'ils ont fait
ici chez omis c'est vachement marine aux
envies de quatre haut parleurs en
partenariat avec harman kardon bloqué
jusque là tout va bien c'est écrit ici
là au dessus emmène quart d'heure on
jette pas la macro mais c'est écrit
juste ici alors même qu arnaud d'alors
l'idée c'est quoi l'idée c'est de se
dire on passe aujourd'hui beaucoup de
temps à venir regarder des films des
séries et du coup alors proposer la
meilleure expérience et vous allez voir
ça c'est intéressant
en fait le truc est très chaud à être
ici et qui est vachement intéressant
c'est qu'on va avoir une expérience
immersive sait qu'on va avoir un spectre
large au niveau des aigus mais au niveau
des rav4 parleurs me direz vous c'est
pas les mêmes ce ne sont pas les mêmes
hauts parleurs non vous avez deux haut
parleurs qui serviront pour les graves
de chaque côté en fin de chaque côté et
deux haut parleurs pour les aigus donc
un de chaque côté d'un 4 par laurent
tout l'idée c'est quoi c'est que vous
ayez des canaux séparés ou le haut
parleur grave a vraiment bien travaillé
que sur le graphe pour vous abordez
cette expérience niveau des graves et
les aigus les aigus bon bref niveau on
se croisait au niveau des fréquences
médium ça me paraissait normal tout ça
pour quoi pour que vous ayez le meilleur
son lorsque vous allez venir regarder un
film social et surtout jouer à des jeux
comme ça parce que les films le général
pour semer des petits casques parce que
bon comme ça c'est sympa mais regardez
pour que ça fonctionne et le truc qui
est intéressant vous savez c'est que
lorsque vous écoutez des haut parleurs
de smartphones plus vous allez montez le
son un moment parce que vous avez un
seul haut-parleur plus il va travailler
à haut niveau et moins il va pouvoir
travailler au niveau des basses et plus
le son va être médium aigu et ici comme
vous avez des hauts parleurs dédié pour
les basses ça vous permet d'avoir à haut
niveau plus de rondeur alors à haut
niveau oui et non parce que quand même
il envoie du sommet jusqu'aux les
smartphones qui vraiment parti ni
davantage mais ce que vous avez là
suffira déjà largement et de
conservation efficace
donc en termes d'expérience france
simple à tétouan monsieur en terme
d'expérience audio / que vraiment
là-dessus ils ont fait un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment bien donc ça ses
premiers points que j'ai trouvé hyper
hyper cool c'est cette expérience audio
maintenant il ya un deuxième point que
j'ai trouvé aussi super intéressant
c'est cette expérience audio vidéo mais
au niveau de l'écran alors je me suis
fait plusieurs je vais vous montrer un
petit jeu ici j'aime bien soit 9 ça me
fait marrer ça prend pas beaucoup de
temps c'est rapide c'est efficace sa
tartine suffisamment et puis la
plantation donc ça j'aime bien regarder
asphalte neuf c'est intéressant pourquoi
parce que déjà voir du bon son niveau de
tout ce qui va être immersion son
inertie 22 h film dont je suis dans ma
course a same player déjà vous avez un
écran qui est super bonne qualité on va
revoir bientôt dans quelques instants ça
s'est super bien en plus de ça vous avez
vachement de performances avec le stade
ragone lui jane un donc ça c'est quand
même vachement cool oh là là je pars
avec atik donc ça c'est vachement bien
en plus de ça je vais avoir 12 giga
draps ni si ces deux là étaient ddr5 je
vais avoir 256 go de stockage en ef s de
poison et l'herbe et hulu paix mais
surtout voyez j'ai cette expérience
immersive avec ce très très bel écran et
je trouve ça juste énorme sur ce
smartphone mandole peuple et qu'il
paierait pour terminer donc c'est
vachement intéressant et on le voit ici
c'est que on a un truc est vachement
complet au niveau de l'expérience j'ai
une superbe qualité d'écran j'ai une
très jolie d'aller social tout qui me
plaît beaucoup sur ce smartphone alors
au delà du fait d'abord je voulais dire
être présenté un autre clé ramon somme
tout ça on s'en fiche un petit poussin
et croquis et lumineux même lorsque vous
allez en extérieur donc ça c'est plutôt
intéressant vous avez vos schémas de
couleur on peut venir régler saturé coup
leurs origines d'un gars moi je me
laisse en intense comme il ya ça me
conviendrait très bien et comme je
voulais présenter vous pouvez monter
jusqu en wqs des plus attention ici à
l'autonomie c'est pas forcément le point
fort de smartphones il n'est pas mauvais
on tient une journée si vous y allez
fort vous tiendrez moins d'une journée
donc w qhd plus c'est bien mais méfiez
vous parce que l'autonomie elle doit
quand même merci donc à ses deux
premiers trous kaki avoir là-dessus taux
d'actualisation vous mettez par défaut
vous posez pas de questions lui va faire
le tape directement lors on peut venir
de personnaliser pouce et 200 hertz tout
le temps mais je pense que ce sera
vraiment grand chose moi ce que je
conseille réellement c'est de rester ici
par défaut il va se débrouiller le fera
dynamiquement comme vous avez une balle
ltp au il fera le taf est sûrement pas
de souci ça sera très très bien donc on
a un superbe écran lumineux lorsque tu
en extérieur avec un bon taux de
rafraîchissement attention wqs de plus
une fois de plus à cause de l'autonomie
beaucoup de performance superbe
expérience audio si vous voulez
connaître la fiche technique un se
produit je vous ai fait déjà une vidéo
pour vous le présenter donc jamais le
lien soit en bas soit ici comme ça vous
verrez la fiche technique et vous verrez
c'est très simple je peux pas vous le
d'énumérer une fois de plus ici à des
petites frayeurs sur le côté c'est parce
que j'ai laissé la protection d'écran
forme de support 2 alors attention il ya
un petit point de détail et je vous
conseille de venir le protéger parce que
regarder moi j'ai une petite marque là
qui est déjà apparu en le laissant
traîner avec moi en mettant dans une
poche en le baladant donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il va avoir tendance
quand même à prendre des marques assez
rapidement alors c'est dommage parce
qu'il est très très joli comme ça et
effectivement bondage le garder comme ça
protéger le ça évitera quand même les
déconvenues parce que ce smartphone j'ai
l'impression qu'il va quand même vous
faire des petites blagues au niveau des
marques des pouvoirs retrouver là dessus
à l'avancé par ayasse km une petite
protection d'écran c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal à regarder une d'original
et c'est là mais si sa marque et si elle
vous embête vous l'enlevez vous embête
une autre moi j'ai déjà marqué voyez
c'est pareil ici alors après c'est
toujours les petits de protection
d'écran qui seront testés goyer laisse
toujours des marques la journée des
petites ici ça sert à ça une protection
d'écran ça sert à protéger très bon pour
le divertissement très bon pour lui mais
avec de la performance maintenant la
question de la batterie on est un peu en
dessous quand même parce qu on a une
batterie de 4600 milliards us il s'est
quand même bien mais vous avez un très
grand écran c'est du 6,73 pouces vous
avez installera gones bien qu'il soit
gréement cattenom est donc il sera quand
même moins énergivores qui va quand même
venir consommer et c'est là où xiaomi
est extrêmement malin et ils ont bien
fait de vous mettre ce bloc de chars 220
watts à l'intérieur pour quoi et bien
tout simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui la
question de l'autonomie elle devient peu
caduque alors je vous en parle je vous
le dis vous garder une bonne journée
sans problème mais si vous jouez
énormément vous garderez moins d'une
journée mais ce qui est cool c'est que
comme vous avez sept blocs de charges
vous prenez vous le branchez vous le
recharger pour une journée en un quart
d'heure n'est pas un carreleur donc
l'autonomie elle devient canu qui on
oublie cette problématique d'autonomie
après le truc qui est quand même un peu
un peu lourdingue et s'il faut le dire
c'est que le bloc de charge il est
justement lourdingue je le trouve pattes
il est loin franchement il est plus
lourd votre smartphone il est beau
couple homo smartphones ce qui
fonctionne ou belzec le smartphone et ça
dans un sac à venir augmenter le poids
alors pour autant ça rend un service a
très clairement c'est énorme ça du 120
watts mais bon il est quand même un peu
l'eau dont vous avez pas le mettre dans
une veine dans la poche d'une veste il
faut prévoir un sac pour venir l'emmener
avec vous parce que du nil est lourd et
2 les massifs ils espèrent dp donc il
veut plus aucun smartphone il est plus
épais que les smartphones mais par
contre on vraiment un service qui est
énorme donc cette question de
l'autonomie aujourd'hui je vous dis une
bonne journée et avec ça vous repartez
pour tout le temps que je n'avais jamais
de problème de recharge donc ça c'est
quand même vachement bien maintenant on
va parler du l'expérience logiciels
alors me why 13 j'aime bien ces versions
internes là on est sur un plan sur un os
et reste qui est entre millau et 12.5
emirates reste elle qui pourrait être
j'ai regardé des vidéos notamment en
inde où on voit un mythe reste quand
même un peu différent et plus avancé
peut-être que chiot mise en garde sous
le coude pour le sortir une mise à jour
dans quelques temps avec des nouvelles
fonctionnalités pour l'instant ce que je
vois là me plaît bien mais je suis sûre
du mur y douze clairement donc c'est un
white ra elle ya des nouveautés mais ça
va vraiment me wade 12 voiliers avec mes
notification de ce côté là mon tiroir
d'applications mes gestes alors si je
veux dire retrouver mais j'ai c'est
pareil c'est un truc qui on peut y aller
un récit cheschire me faut vous alliez
dans vos paramètres parce que sinon ces
navigations par bouton alors je vous le
dis ce soir de le savoir vous allez dans
l'écran d'accueil et dans l'écran
d'accueil vous venez dans ce système de
navigation ici et vous venez mettre par
un geste parce que sinon vous avez les
boutons c'est pas terrible d'avoir les
boutons par défaut je reprenne ses
règles chirino mettre les gestes par
défaut après l'expérience allait pas mal
à en faire trop une fois qu'on a compris
comment ça fonctionne et on a des
petites icônes on se retrouve on peut
venir personnalisé changer les faux
l'écran et compagnie mais j'attends
toujours la vraie version 2013 tels que
j'ai pu la voir et bien chez d'autres
copains qui font des vidéos en inde et
que je trouve beaucoup plus pertinent
est beaucoup plus intéressant et on va
plus loin en termes de personnalisation
autre point qui est intéressant qui
étaient améliorées il ya une mise à jour
qui vient supprimer un peu sur chaleur
combi retrouver au dos du smartphone
notamment ici lorsqu'on est en train de
jouer donc cette mise à jour m'a permis
de gommer ça c'est plutôt intéressant
donc ça va ça fonctionne et puis surtout
la grosse promesse qui fait ici qu
intéressante c'est le triptyque photo
parce que vous avez 50 50 53 x 50 alors
vous avez pas 150 le vous avez 50 sur le
grand-angle 50 sur le très bon temps les
50 sur le téléobjectif est ce que ça
fonctionne c'est 50 c'est ce qu'on va
regarder alors déjà je vous dis tout de
suite je vous le monde frank biller - ya
des trucs qui me pèse pas trop ici
regardez on va au niveau de la partie
photo le capteur principal il est bien
il est stabilisé optiquement ça ne
fonctionne bien et ça ça me va bien
aller j'ai essayé de mettre un truc pour
vous voyez donc ça c'est cool maintenant
il ya un truc que chez tommy a pas fait
que je trouve quand même dommage c'est
que lorsque vous passez sur votre télé
objectif là vous avez pas stable optique
ça n'est pas si vous êtes là je prends
ma main qui tremble voilà moi j'ai un
tremblement essentiel ça bouge à l'écran
alors lorsque je suis sur le grand angle
ça me corrige quand même pas mal sur l'
ultra grand-angle j'ai pas non plus de
stable c'est vraiment la merde mais
lorsque je suis voyez sur le
téléobjectif et ben j'aurais bien aimé
que ce soit mieux stabilisé chose s'est
vraiment rendu compte en allant faire
des photos je me dis ah le grand temps
il est nickel déstabiliser mais
d'exposer sur ce téléobjectif en fois de
gym à sa mouche quoi le x 2 et bouger
c'est dommage alors après lorsque
j'augmente hinx passant x 5 x 10 points
devant vers la d1 qualité dans quelques
instants vous verrez le résultat on a ri
parce qu'on est stabilisé
électroniquement donc ça se fait d'un
point de vue logiciel et ça fonctionne
mais x 2 n'est pas stabilisé et ça c'est
dommage pour un smartphone inscrire je
vous montre des photos que j'ai prises
action smartphones y en a eu plusieurs
j'ai fait un petit riche du monde deux
trois trucs alors là j'ai vraiment voulu
tester voir que ça racontait au niveau
de l'arbre sur jeté hier un contre-jour
mais en prend en photo le ciel même si
le ciel était pas dingue mais regardez
ça c'est intéressant parce que on voit
quand même plutôt pas mal les détails
des bronches une part assez normal le
petit coin de ciel bleu on voit bien les
petits détails au niveau des nuages on
voit bien ici la regarder tout ce qu'on
va retrouver ici au niveau des branches
pareil ici ça me paraît quand même
peut-être pas mal on va bien petit
bourgeon peut-être donc là ça fonctionne
plutôt bien sur l'ultra grand angle
c'est aussi quand même plutôt pas mal
vous allez voir quelle petite différence
de colorimétrie entre le canton et les
travaux en temps mais rien d'étonnant
ici ça fonctionne on a les petits
détails on a bien le ciel et où les
compagnies donc tout va bien ça c'est un
x 2 on peut se rapprocher un peu en x 2
x 2 ça va très bien on est sur le
téléobjectif fois de aux petits marche
pas de souci dès qu'on arrive en fois ça
qu'on est sur du numérique alors là on
se rend pas compte ça n'a pas trop mal
et d'un point de vue algorithmique
effectivement ils viennent bien
souligner les traits donc ça ira x 10 on
voit quand même qui vient déjà un petit
peu tirés et on voit que ça vient
compenser et que ça vient et lycées et
le x 20 bon ben voilà c'est ses habitats
alors ça c'est très très très très jolie
cette photo parce que je trouve que les
couleurs alors ils sont rhdp saturé par
rapport à ce qu'on trouve en réalité
mais c'est l'idée façon des smartphones
de shlomi sont comme ça il est toujours
un peu sursaturé pour embellir la vérité
néanmoins du détail c'est très joli ça
fonctionne bien ça me plaît bien je suis
pas si sûr ultra-grand-angle alors il
m'a fait le point dessus mais on va
quand même que les couleurs sont quand
même plutôt pas mal et on vient où mes
fois de ici est le téléobjectif sur sa
très jolie franchement ça fonctionne
même si on bloque son côté là alors
c'est moi qui bougeraient c'est tout le
problème effectivement ici de ne pas
avoir de stabilisation sur ce x 2 der
garde et on perd un petit peu légèrement
précisions sur le côté on avance en x 5
on voit qu'on perd déjà en qualité
attention ça c'est assez normal le x 17
x 20 bon c'est pas ouf complètement on
continue ici sur un paysage sur votre
grand angle sous que ça marche vraiment
bien on a aussi bien les détails de
vandales ciel alors c'est que le aussi
allégué en fait aujourd'hui on sait pas
que c'est cramé spéciale est vraiment
pas terrible on a tous les points des
tailles de tous les côtés et ça
fonctionne bien vraiment l' ultra
grand-angle on perd un peu en précision
mais c'est normal mais ça reste malgré
tout très cohérent le x 2 2 x 5 qui
vient lycée et qui est moins bon le x 10
et il faut 20 qui n'est pas bon du tout
le capteur principal fait vraiment bien
le boulot sauf que là tu shiomi a bien
poussé sa copie c'est vraiment bien
réussi l'ultra grand temps braud fra le
taf le foie de volaille au delà du x 2
c'est pas terrible ce qui fait qu'on ait
un truc qui fonctionne vraiment bien
c'est ce triptyque grand angle ultra
grand angle au téléobjectif à 2 au delà
de ça on perd en qualité et c'est là que
seront fraîches hiromi avait une carte à
jouer à nous proposons tout peut-être
plus intéressant comme ce café au pot
avec deux téléobjectifs ça aurait pu
être intéressant parce que je reste un
peu sur ma faim au niveau du
téléobjectif au niveau du zoom et je
trouve qu'on va pas assez loin et c'est
un peu dommage par ici jouent donc la
même chose regarder une petite
différence de colorimétrie entre le
grand temps minutes racontant leurs
gardes et notamment ici quand angle
ultra grand-angle c'est un peu plus
palau ce poids du caudan ça me dérange
pas en l'air un peu plus loin le x 2 et
au delà de savent rien qu'ils sont un
peu la même histoire ici aussi mais ça
c'est quand même assez cohérente maison
quand même plutôt bien bosser alors on
va le voir vraiment surtout ici la
regarder au niveau de l'herbe entre
votre grand angle et votre
ultra-grand-angle qui va être un peu
plus jeunes gardez voyez cette partie
que vous avez là vers cette partie que
vous avez là c'est peut-être du point de
détail mais malgré tout donc ensuite hop
j'avance bon toujours un peu les mêmes
choses alors la caméra de celle fille je
suis vraiment pas fan je trouve que je
suis en vie et c'est pas nouveau c'est
chez home is et leur traitement ils
viennent trop lisse et les pots et c'est
dommage parce qu'il ya un côté un peu
fake peau de bébé qui marchent pas c'est
pas vrai que c'est pas ma peau ma peau
elle est pas aussi lisse et que ça
allait pas aussi mail elle est un peu
plus dégueu elle prenait gbabgo les
gamins paumés riez il ya quand même une
différence entre ça ça c'est ma peau et
ça voyez il ya une différence quand même
donc ça ça ne marche pas et ça pour moi
et c'est un truc qui n'est pas super
alors j'ai essayé différentes manières
mais je trouve que c'est trop trop trop
lisse et c'est trop flatteur alors pour
autant il sait très bien bossé au niveau
des contre-jours et toucy et tout ça il
le gère bien mais ils disent davantage
et voilà je trouve ça pas terrible bon
encore des petites photos de chou un peu
la même histoire alors le mode portrait
il fonctionne plutôt pas mal villa un
peu plus de mal ici au niveau de l
humeur mais ça me paraît pas d'écho noah
c'est intéressant parce que comme on est
sur un processeur extrêmement performant
on a tout ce qu'il faut derrière donc il
sait bien des tours et mais on voit un
poil la limite qu'on n'aurait pas avec
un capteur tough qu'ils viendraient
vraiment effectivement être bien
meilleur il ya deux points intéressants
dans cette photo le premier c'est la
petite boucle de 2 ma veste lac qui n'a
pas du tout eu qu'il a complètement
perdu et 61.2 tech un peu moins bon
regarder la boucle de la baisse alors il
a complètement loupé y aurait un capteur
tough il aurait donc là c'est vous voyez
un peu l'arctique points de faiblesse et
là au niveau de la main c'est parce
qu'il a fait il a vu un bout de man plus
sur le côté je sais pas il m'a rajouté
une verrue j'en sais rien je trouve que
voilà ces photos là c'est intéressant
parce qu'on voit effectivement qu'un
bien qu'on a un bon processeur derrière
le fait qu'on n'est pas un petit capteur
pogba et on a quelques petites limites
alors après j'ai changé toujours le
problème de la boucle qui a disparu là
j'ai plus la verrue sur la main donc ça
ça va et la boucle à elle revient
pourquoi parce qu'on a un arbre derrière
je pense et il a eu un peu plus de
facilité sur cette scène alors après je
vois un truc assez intéressant c'est une
photo prise dans le noir noir absolu on
voit rien pour autant regarder c'est
vachement intéressant parce que ça me
sort des photos que je trouve assez
clair donc il ya un beau travail au
niveau des conditions nuit ici quand
même plutôt pas mal géré ici c'est
pareil mêmes conditions à lumière on
voit rien et lui il sort et on voit très
bien donc très très bluffant là dessus
idem sur cette photo là j'ai juste mis
un tout petit peu lumière vraiment
planck est posé sur le côté pas de
lumière dans la pièce est vraiment pas
éclairé vers moi c'est vraiment posé la
lumière à plat on voit pas grand chose
et pour autant ça nous sort un truc qui
marche vraiment donc là dessus vous
voyez quand conditions nuit de faible
luminosité en intérieur son sens
vraiment bien côté photo nuit qu'est ce
que ça raconte dans l'ensemble c'est
plutôt pas mal photo prise à la main à
la volée pas de trépied ici c'est plutôt
bien et les gestions niveau de lumière
est pas parfaite on le voit ici mais bon
vous me direz c'est du point de détail
le très grand entre clermont en oublie
mais ça c'est pas nouveau et c'est pas
que sur ce smartphone donc on va pas
mettre d'ultra vantant les six l'année
je trouve que dans l'ensemble c'est
plutôt bien et vous le verrez mais il ya
une petite gestion niveau des lumières
qui va être un peu un peu moyenne
moyenne comme beaucoup de smartphones
ceci étant dit là dessus une fois de
plus je monte plus très longtemps ils
sortent quand pareil avec le grand temps
que tout de suite beaucoup mieux très
clairement on a néanmoins un détail qui
est plutôt correct plutôt convenable on
voit bien le ciel on voit bien les
détails on a bien l'air neuf ans je le
peux envoyer surtout fait part ici donc
ça c'est assez laide plutôt pas mal fait
on vend une fois de plus qu'il a un
petit peu de mal ici alors je crois que
j'avais calais mes mains ici sur un tir
en coin et j'ai l'impression que c'est
un peu moins pressé si ce qui a eu un
petit mouvement je sais pas mais là oui
c'est un peu moins bien là ici pareil je
m'étais calais posé et là franchement
c'est nickel la gestion des lumières est
très bonne la dessus aucun problème même
au niveau du ciel de la maison assez top
ça marche l'appareil voyais au niveau
des lumières c'est un peu moins bien
mais franchement dans l'ensemble c'est
vraiment très bien en termes de photos
nuit vraiment donc c'est vraiment
histoire de devenir à chipoter on
continue ici c'est sensiblement la même
chose les pieds plumes hier mais c'est
très léger sinon c'est bien on voit bien
à la fois l'arbre ici on voit bien le
dos des bons ici on voit bien l'impasse
et d'éclairer tout est correct la même
chose sensiblement ici à peu près pareil
ici et là j'ai voulu tenter sur des
petites fleurs alors effectivement n'est
pas comme en plein jour on a moins de
saturation ce qui est normal mais dans
l'ensemble c'est pas mal franchement en
garde et a bien une petite fleur bon on
voit que c'est la nuit en clamant pour
moi ça fait l'état autre point qui me
chagrine un peu sur ce smartphone c'est
qu'on n'a aucune certification de
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
alors pour autant ça veut pas dire qu'il
va craindre indique qu'il va rencontrer
un peu d'eau ça veut pas dire que s'il
ya de la poussière qui s'approche il
faut partir en courant et ça va le
changer non c'est pas vrai seulement ça
veut dire que j'ai omis n'a pas payé de
certification n'a pas cherché à faire
certifier ses smartphones une
certification ça se paye smartphones par
smartphone dès qu'un smartphone est
vendu il ya une partie dans le tarif qui
part à la certification ils sont libres
ils sont mignons mais on veut pas payer
ça donc vous avez un smartphone à plus
de 1000 euros qui n'est pas certifié et
du point de vue du consommateur trouve
ça un peu dommage il ya un côté qui est
un petit peu voilà on vous dit
mince couac est infléchi omis pour
autant je suis persuadé alors je n'ai
pas acheté sous l'eau mais je suis
persuadé qu'il n'y aura aucun problème
s'il va rencontrer de l'eau et compagnie
c'est un très joli smartphone je trouve
choix elle se trouve bien bossé je
trouve intéressante chez xiaomi super
l'expérience une fois de plus pour le
multimédia point gaming et sont des
usages extrêmement fort il est très bon
photos notamment sur le capteur
principal il ira bien on va pas aller
aussi loin que ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer avec un smartphone à ce prix là
sur un zoom x 30 voyez où ce qu'a pu
proposer au pot avec un zoom à foix iii
et un deuxième téléobjectif avec un zoom
x 10 en optique ici c'est pas le cas
alors je me dis que ça me paraîtrait
logique qu'ils aillent là dessus aussi
voyez qu'on est plus loin au niveau de
cette partie photo donc j'espère
attendre voir arriver peut-être un
xiaomi 12 ultras qui viendraient aller
plus loin au niveau de la photo de jour
de nuit déjà même si c'est pas mal ce
serait intéressant on ne sait vraiment
ce que j'attends je serais pas surpris
qu'il arrive si il arrive pas il
manquerait un peu ce truc boyer il se
dirait il manque un truc dans le line-up
il manque quelque chose on va aller plus
haut niveau de la photo pour être au
niveau des heures parce que je le dis
une fois de plus on est à quasiment 1100
euros 1000
99.90 donc il faut passer un petit truc
pour aller plus loin en photo une fois
de plus et schumi était pas attendu sur
le très haut de gamme ils sont arrivés
sont positionnés là ils ont dit nous
aussi on est capable de le faire je
pense qu'il manque un petit dernier truc
en photo stabiliser votre télé objectif
je pense qu'ils manquent également le
fait de se dire on va aller plus loin
moi je voudrais infodis nickel je peins
faut disent qu'ils soient un peu pixo je
veux pas de ça je veux vraiment aller le
plus loin et avec la meilleure qualité
avec un smartphone à 1100 euros voilà ce
que j'avais à vous dire aujourd'hui sur
ce smartphone de chimie que je trouve
vraiment intéressant d pas ce que vous
en pensez vous on va encore monter avec
moi vous trouvez vous trouve intéressant
ce qui peut vous plaire est ce que vous
pourriez vous acheter un smartphone à
1100 euros chez sur wii est ce que vous
l'avez fait est ce que vous le feriez si
vous êtes client de chez tommy est ce
que ça vous rassure est ce que vous
auriez envie et si vous n'êtes pas
client le shérif est ce que vous
pourriez aller c'est vraiment curieux de
voir ça parce que je ne demande jamais
pu jauger en fait la proportion de vous
deux personnes qui avaient envie
d'acheter un smartphone chaumié mais ce
n'est pas ce que vous en pensez si vous
avez 1100 euros de budget est ce que
vous le mettez auriez chez omis est ce
que vous le mettez auriez chez samsung
est ce que vous le maître yeshe aux
prouesses que vous ne mettriez chez
apple dites le moi en bas en commentaire
on se retrouve très vite pour continuer
à parler avec vous embrasse tous les
soirs où il ya très bien des cas
[Musique]